a whole two unsuccessful three perhaps
successful so here's the kicker to the
whole thing I'm now married to a lovely
dwarf and and who you have to believe in
in order for her powers to this is a
Tinkerbell and we were we were four
years we were trying to have a kid and
we had a we had a very difficult time
having a kid by the way it was like
really not not easy for us and we'd like
we did the regular way which was fun but
uneventful at the end and then we went
through IVF and mm-hmm
that didn't work and then you want to
hear this story yeah we love it yeah
pretty sweet story actually so we went
through so we tried raw dog [ __ ] for a
while which is the clinical term is
blasting in the sugar walls yeah that
didn't work and hmm and then we went
through IVF which is so hardcore it's
like for the woman it's so gnarly like
it was like [ __ ] injecting Natasha's
ass with like syringes every one every
night and like like her whole butt was
black and blue and like my god and she
was him hormonal and like like crying
and it was just really hard and it was
to try to harvest these eggs it's like
you're like some kind of like alien
organism it's like some farm or whatever
it's like back to Mobius yeah and then
they couldn't harvest them and she had
these eggs that were frozen that she had
you know
Natasha's set was all about like I'll
never have I'll never be pregnant for
long or having a baby it's like a DUI
from the universe these are like yeah
name of her of her stand up yeah some
weird reason she had frozen five five
eggs or eight eggs before she met me
before we started dating and mmm
and she so he went through trying to get
these harvested eggs and the doctor kept
saying like don't use the frozen eggs
don't use the frozen eggs and he would I
remember this conversation he I remember
by the way he sat down he had hair plugs
and a vape yeah although I did go to a
doctor recently and I he was like do you
smoke and I was like no I vape he's like
oh that's cool I was like what
anyway this doctor was like you don't
want to use the frozen eggs you got to
think of the frozen eggs is like your
savings account right and and what we're
trying to harvest these are less like
building up your checking account and I
was like thinking to myself like please
do not use a bank account in this most
expense it was like $10,000 around Wow
gnarly Wow he's like think of it I was
like oh gee your your savings I guess
I'm like yeah anyway we finally gave up
and we decided to do the eggs and the
frozen eggs and we thought them out and
it was eight eggs and four of them
survived do you do it at home how do you
yeah you put in the microwave the little
holder right so you know that they the
ones that survive when you home you know
the ones that survive ones that don't
cuz the ones that don't survive they
states there's like a sort of a death
scream right sea-monkeys you put them in
water we'll just see what happens
no they do don't they do it yeah
so they thought they thought I'm an only
four survived out of eight now we're
down to four oh my god then they tested
them all for you know different stuff
yeah and only two survived now we're
down to two and then we implanted one
and it failed and so now we're down to
one we're kind of at this point we're
going like you know what [ __ ] it adopt
adopt or just go to Europe you know
spend our lives having fun like you guys
having a good time you know like it was
almost sort of like there was something
kind of relieving about in a way was
likely you know we'll just be like
people about kids and have fun and just
whatever then we implanted the last one
and that's our daughter right and yet
it's like it feels miraculous in a way
and they were telling her by the way
they're like it's like 40% it's like I
said at The Comedy Store that's what
they said like I said at the Tommy era
comedy yeah yeah and and and now we have
this like super awesome kid that's like
funny and talking and she's making jokes
and she's good because I the last time I
talked to you guys about your kid was um
when he she wasn't talking right now is
we're not calling her is she right what
is it
it's a girl it is it's a girl what's her
name that were not saying oh yeah yeah
oh yeah so uh sweets sweets yeah so
sweets was I'm not talking all that
stuff but then now sweets is
communicating totally and well in what
way and like funny like that like I
guess it was doomed to be funny but like
she is she cracks jokes and stuff like
it Wow it's kind of mean they're not
good yes but it's like oh you and she
likes attention she likes like run up to
the front of a group and kind of do a
thing and like she's clearly got a
performer buggin dry right I'm not
stoked you know I would have preferred
like oh wow a scientist I didn't see
that coming yeah but I definitely feel
like she's a bit of a performer and
she's awesome
she's great but um but but but is the
fake because I've heard dude say or
women so yeah at the beginning is rough
right but then once they start
communicating it becomes more arm not
meaningful but like it just becomes fun
or well it's definitely a lot funner and
for the for the first like year it's
kind of like you just have a slug a
little flesh slug that you have to keep
alive because then then you have like
murder charges if you don't come on slug
but it's cute and stuff thank God they
say like they say babies are cute so
that we won't just be like [ __ ] that
like but then they start talking but
then you know I was thinking about this
the other day you know how bit boring
children are like how you like it's
unbelievable how boring they are like
you can't believe the conversation you
want to die when you talk to a kid yeah
yeah like there's this beautiful kind of
like mathematics of emotional connection
to obey your baby because like the only
person that could ever care about a
conversation with a baby that's going
like um me like purple me like purple
daddy drink coffee
daddy drink you of you of you heard that
be like [ __ ] yeah daddy drink coffee
together do you have anything else to
say
dumbass yeah yeah I'm I am fascinated by
because I remember her when she was like
so I see like whoa you say Danny drink
coffee now you used to the maze-like
[ __ ] and puke like yeah yeah it's like
parents are like coded to think that
it's interesting because Tim to me it's
[ __ ] fascinating because I've seen
every
strand Oh development do you look for
because I hear dudes go because Carla
and I are through been talking about let
me guess who wants I want that way
actually you don't oh yeah I know
interesting it's not the other way yeah
kind of